so that's one of the major realities of
YouTube and one of the reasons why I was
like always so [ __ ] up looking in
every Vlog that I was on of my exes
because when you get the public telling
you everything about you where's your
upper lip why is your forehead so big
why is your skin so white all this [ __ ]
like just you you just get barraged with
all the things that are not absolutely
perfect about you and I think it's just
because like either they were picked on
a little bit or like when people all
these little kids now they want to be
famous I'm like you don't know what
you're signing about the physical
appearance that they nitpick it's your
entire personality anything that you
give yeah it's wrong it is you start to
Lose Yourself you start to self-edit
yeah you're like who the [ __ ] am I
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of big
mood hi how you doing how's your health
unclunt your jaw loosen your shoulders
sit up straight you [ __ ] crooked ass
[ __ ] you scoliosis [ __ ] shaped like a
leather s [ __ ] now a leather s do they
say leather letter s [ __ ] yeah leather
that's like why leather skin leather to
you
ampersands [ __ ] shaped [ __ ]
I'm surprised you know that word right
good for you hi brain good you're kind
of smart sometimes sometimes God I'm
decent looking though otherwise
um I want to be rough for you one of my
favorite insults for dumb people it's
like
you should marry Rich
that's like bless your heart bless your
heart very rich anyhow uh who do we have
here we have our big star from Austin
Texas by the big stars because everyone
misses you about that because I'm just
gone a lot you miss what you don't have
no if I was here all the time it would
be like God tell this [ __ ] to shut up
no because they appreciate your opinion
they think you're funny yeah big who is
it Jessica
I still gotta change your name on my
phone
yeah you know how many [ __ ] years
it's been I know even matter
I mean Nikki still has me as uh Tiff JK
news
that's hilarious I changed people's
stuff like pretty instantly if my
relationship with them changes oh really
yeah sometimes I'll change I'll change
her name to like
mean ass [ __ ]
don't answer ass [ __ ]
and also who else do we have oh yeah I
mean Tiff
yeah and then also who else would we
have nibbler
he doesn't talk he's licking himself
he's cleaning himself he's being clean
he's a good boy
um okay so uh last last episode that we
filmed we did relationship advice that
we took from Reddit posts
um because they were so [ __ ] juicy it
was really so good yeah I was invested
yeah I wanted more so we decided
we're gonna do more yeah because not the
audience but I kind of am in a way yeah
like your audience and I want you to
tell me more of these stories so
hopefully you guys are along for the
ride yeah we're just like they judge
people you know people have problems we
are so she's you know it's funny one
time when Isaac was little
um he wanted to know something and I was
like no Isaac like you're too young like
you can't know or whatever he goes come
on Mom you know me you know you you know
us you know the way we are I'm like oh
God negotiating where did he come up
with this
we like to sit yeah he's like
like nosy pretty much and oh my God ever
since he said that I think he was like
eight or something since then like
that's like my favorite thing to say
every time like every time he I want to
know something of his yeah he's like no
Mom no it's okay and I'm like come on
you know me you know you you know you
know the way we are it sounds like he
was watching mafia movies like come on
yeah yeah we're family yeah yeah you're
mine I'm Yours just tell me you can
trust me you know that's so cute yeah I
love that he's gonna be a little cheese
muscle he already is
um okay so
pulled up a bunch of posts that I
thought sounded interesting just by the
title so I'm going into this blind too I
don't know what's going on and we're
gonna judge these people give them
relationship advice keep in mind that
they're not just romantic relationships
it's friendships family all that stuff
all right the first one I found
is
just looking at it makes me laugh my
friend and I have a YouTube channel
together
people think I'm the ugly one oh okay
how old how old are these kids
people think how many Subs do they have
are you even worthy of us talking about
you oh my god do you know who I am
we don't have views anymore
because you're on TV doesn't mean we can
talk like this you're lucky we're even
talking about you anyways pay us our fee
because we're promoting you right now
just kidding that's silly I'm a piece of
[ __ ] so that's one of the major
realities of YouTube and one of the
reasons why I was like always so [ __ ]
up looking in every Vlog that I was on
of my exes because when you get the
public telling you everything about you
where's your upper lip why is your
forehead so big why is your skin so
white all this [ __ ] like just you you
just get barraged with all the things
that are not absolutely perfect about
you and I think it's just because like
either they were picked on a little bit
or like it's easy to kind of like it's
entertaining to like or maybe they don't
know
they're just like yeah it feels good
when people all these little kids now
they want to be famous I'm like you
don't know what you're signing off your
physical appearance that they nitpick
it's your entire personality yeah
anything that you give yeah it's wrong
it is you start to Lose Yourself you
start to self-edit yeah you're like who
the [ __ ] am I you can kind of go crazy
like yep thinking about what everyone is
saying about you she's the ugly one now
apparently which that could be totally
different depending on the year what's
in Trend what's in fashion one year the
black girls are ugly the next year
they're the the top [ __ ] and the white
girls are ugly like this stuff is just
ridiculous it's not based in reality
yeah it comes from like a severe
insecurity because I feel like they look
at you and they're like oh she's famous
why well [ __ ] her like yeah she's just
blue eyes
she's got a pointy nose yeah she has no
upper lip why does that person gets me
famous but not me it's because she has
blue eyes man [ __ ] blue eyes yeah I hate
your blue eyes like it's like that it's
like deep insecurities yeah hit and then
like it's a hide behind their computer
too but it's exactly anonymity like I
think like why does that person get to
be famous but not me I think I'll just
Fame either it's just like literal like
just okay so my cousin in Mexico
she has had a YouTube channel since she
was like in middle school and this is
and she's already like
oh she's like 26 I think
25. anyway so a long long time ago
before everyone had a YouTube channel
like she she had her own thing she was
trying to do like makeup and like DIY
stuff and she was just she had her own
little corner of the internet carved out
for herself and like whoever would
follow her and her Channel like wasn't
big or anything but she just had like
her own little thing and [ __ ] at her
school kept picking on her and saying
like oh what you think you're that
important like you think you're that
cute like you think like people actually
want to hear what you have to say and
like they would bully her all the time
and also my cousin like she's not like
you know
traditionally like shaped you know she's
like a bigger girl so she would end up
that is traditional you know what I mean
like for the standards of what is like
acceptable or whatever she's on for me
media for media media for media that's
what I mean thank you for clarifying so
for my cousin she would end up getting
bullied for her weight too and like
saying like why does anyone want to see
a big girl like on YouTube like what are
you doing like you're doing makeup
tutorials you don't even know how to do
your makeup like literally
just tearing her apart and my I love my
cousin because she was always like I
don't give a [ __ ] what they're saying
though like I literally I don't care I'm
still gonna have my YouTube channel I I
don't I don't care that I don't have a
million subscribers I this is what I do
and I really love it and it's my passion
I have fun and I'm gonna keep going yeah
yeah I'm like yeah good for you that's
pretty strong oh God this reminds me
when I was 19 years old and I was like
you know like back then Facebook like
you've lost whatever you post whatever
anything you want I remember I posted a
picture of my nails like I just did my
nails here I'm so happy because I was
super into it back then and there's this
girl named Alex that was like she she
just commented she was my friend's
girlfriend that was around all the time
and she commented I'm so [ __ ] sick of
this Gina nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
nails or anything like you you're like a
Tila Tequila wannabe you're not famous
nobody cares who you are
like that and this one like in this
beginning of my career when I was like
modeling you know I was Go-Go dancing so
I was like just starting off you know on
Instagram I was like trying to bring you
down yeah she's like I don't nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you Gina and then I
messaged her I was like whoa
okay yeah what was that she goes you
have nothing of substance and blah blah
nobody cares I'm like you're on Facebook
looking for substance yeah
anyways um found out later she was a
massive druggie and uh I'm better than
Felix healing now because I'm not a
[ __ ] there we go
deals a lot more than racist she's got a
lot going on saying I'm not a Nazi it's
like a little mentally unstable yeah all
right let's get into it so the topic is
my friend and I have a YouTube channel
together people think I'm the ugly one
we're both 18 plus our channel has just
under 10 000 Subs I'm calling my friend
Sarah which is not her real name I'm
just being big I always knew that I
wasn't the pretty one we've been friends
since we were really young and I've Seen
Her Go from Awkward kids really really
pretty in school people always ask her
out and they do extra stuff stuff for
her that she never seemed to notice I
used to be jealous but we've talked
about it and how I felt about it back
then
I have a boyfriend who makes me feel
beautiful now Etc I thought I was over
it recently since we gained more
subscribers people have been making
comments about how sad it must be to be
the ugly one Jesus
some of them say my name but most of
them talk about my features that make it
obvious that they're talking about me
I've even had people privately message
me to suggest plastic surgery oh my God
that's the internet for you you all want
to be famous you really don't want this
[ __ ] it's hurting my relationship with
Sarah I know she's prettier than me but
until this it wasn't really a problem
anymore being compared to her constantly
is hurtful she suggested that we both
make our Instagrams private and make a
joint public one so that we can better
control the new hatred towards me I'm
worried that we'll just bring up
questions and I'll have to explain that
I'm so hurt by people saying this stuff
and it's damaging my friendship so much
that we've both had to be private she
even suggested that it gets too bad we
could phase out the channel because it's
not worth becoming bitter towards each
other because of YouTube
I just want to know how to feel better
about being friends with her Sarah has
never made me feel ugly it's always been
other people she's the kindest person I
know and it makes me even more annoyed
because I know she doesn't have control
over this any more than I do I'm not
going to tell anyone the channel it's
insanely unlikely that you'll be
interested in our very Niche subject and
I'd find it really uncomfortable that
certain fans knew what I was dealing
with before I'm ready to speak out about
it publicly also I think it would count
as self-advertising and I don't want the
post to be deleted yeah I mean this was
posted two years ago so later YouTube
that just also in general in life like
being the ugly one you have to deal with
it like there's there's pretty privilege
there's pretty privilege it exists and
it's [ __ ] up like I don't know why you
would if you're having this much of a
hard time like why you want to continue
yeah because like nothing like what are
you gonna do to change it you either
have to love yourself entirely and know
like not everyone is the hot one not
everyone is a smart one not everyone is
the bombshell not everyone you know what
I mean like whatever your strength is
like you he's a funny one whatever it is
or like the the smart one the one that
like you know there's there's like a an
angle for you and you matter more than
just what you look like right so it's
like if you're only focused on what you
look like and that's your only value
because your friend is the hot one then
it's like you're never gonna enjoy this
you might as well stop yeah like because
it's only going to get worse the more
subscribers you get the more [ __ ]
[ __ ] start flooding in like it's
gonna get worse so it's definitely
internal like sure it's something you're
gonna have to deal with that's exactly
my take on it too where it's like if
she's it's either deal with it on your
own
or just phase yourself out of the
channel or to phase a channel out and
the fact that the friend is so
supportive and so loving and so
empathetic is so awesome that she's has
such a good friend but yeah like for her
to not deal with it though like
internally because you're never gonna
control what people say about you that's
never yeah she may not even be that ugly
is the thing is like she's probably like
looks like everybody else if she
probably could have a glow up or
something but she just feels ugly too
and that's just like this is a bigger
problem than like what some commenters
are saying like oh I'm the ugly one like
and this is a problem it's like she's
probably still also super pretty you
know what I mean it just doesn't believe
it now or something you know what I mean
or even if she's not super pretty then
it's like she's got value beyond that
this is for some reason she's focusing
way too much on this but like this
because everyone does obviously Focus
too much on that but it's like we all
like even the prettiest thing too like
that Fades right like we're all gonna be
like
ugly and ignored like at some point like
where people are gonna stop I will kill
myself they're gonna stop noticing us
when we walk around right like we're
gonna get we're gonna be the old person
who's ugly and wrinkly and saggy and
like then what then we don't matter now
or whatever so it's just like we gotta
deal with like we're gonna lose whatever
it is that we think is so valuable
anyways yeah so this also comes down to
like
and I say this all the time being a
public figure really is not for everyone
it's not it's so [ __ ] hot even for
the really pretty people yeah like the
absolute tens they get [ __ ]
obliterated constantly as well there is
no way to satisfy the public no like the
most successful with millions of
followers on social media they're still
getting [ __ ] shot on yeah hundreds of
times a day yeah it's not made for
everyone you know like it's like some
people handle it better like people come
up to me like how do you handle all this
on you I'm like because I just really
don't care but not everyone's like me
and not everyone's like us that can
handle this so if me and I can't even
really handle it I mean like well you're
getting like a [ __ ] seven on the
Internet is hard enough like I can't
imagine being like a four and a female
and like trying to like and then still
being insecure and caring about that is
my angle like you can't like you gotta
let that go like you're it's not gonna
change like if you're not a 10 you just
gotta let it go well you know what I
mean like you still have value so yeah
absolutely yeah that's right it's kind
of like because I'm not one of those
people that I'm cut out for this I just
want to like phase myself out too
because I'm like okay like I didn't
really want to be and turned into this
yeah for a beauty contest
yeah I was like okay well I entered this
space let me give you my everything and
then like dealing with how it was
received a lot of people loved it a lot
of people hated it I'm just like whoa
this is a lot and I can't handle this so
let me just
go in my little corner yeah I see like
the follower count dwindling the views
dwindling yeah and that it should make
me like really worried but it actually
makes me feel relieved right because I'm
like okay cool yeah
unless people are waiting for you and
waiting to comment waiting to [ __ ] on
you like waiting to [ __ ] yeah it
feels like it feels like I'm I'm not
like being grasped anymore I don't know
how to describe it yeah but it feels
I'll leave you like relieving a little
bit but like I said it should definitely
scare me because this is my livelihood
yeah and I'm supposed to continue to
want to be relevant
but I'm just like I'm done yeah it takes
its toll on people for me personally I
still love it so much like I'm still
very heavily into this not only just
social media but now on television yeah
you know
um
and
I can honestly say it's like those
things stop bothering me like maybe a
decade ago because it's like
the way I see it is like I said earlier
it's a deep insecurity with them and
that's their problem
um and two it doesn't bother my bank
account at all and three the way like
sometimes I think of it like oh my God
there's all these people who talked all
this [ __ ] about me
saying I'm this and I'm that but then
things have just been getting better
like my career has just gotten better so
clearly what they say just really does
not matter at all yeah so it's like it's
two different mindsets here you know
like it's not made for everyone and some
people thrive in this yeah right so for
like these two 10 000 right now it's
it's not a lot compared to like you know
how YouTube algorithm once you get to
like a hundred thousand yeah like the
amount of comments are gonna get worse
yeah like the in the how nasty they are
too it's gonna get worse because they
feel like they they disappear in the
crowd yeah like they get to spew their
hatred and ugliness yeah so it's easier
oh yeah either they want you to hear it
or they don't think you will but either
way it's like it's they feel like they
get drowned in the crowd but it's still
very like you know it's not oh yeah
there's been so many comments where
people will talk [ __ ] and I I'd respond
sometimes because and they're like oh I
didn't think you would see this it's
like so you only did this because you
thought you were drowning the crowd
you're a little coward yeah you know but
like I was saying earlier 10 000 right
now is like still in the lower numbers
and if it's hard for you to deal with it
now yeah it's only gonna get worse only
get worse
um so either you work on this yourself
and you really understand these people
really don't matter or maybe this just
isn't the right
path for you you know either way you're
still worthy like you're still beautiful
yeah because it's really going to be on
you like your friend is not doing
anything wrong she's not like making you
feel a type of way like you're gonna be
your own self-destruction and it clearly
was already in the past in their in
their history and the friends just like
he's like I don't know I'm sorry I I'll
support you we can shut the channel down
that's not as important as our
friendship your mental health like yeah
the thing is like they could potentially
if they have a good chemistry and
they're actually really entertaining she
could wind up being really [ __ ]
successful if she could just like figure
out a way to get through this but even I
can't figure out a way to get through
public opinion so like I would let it go
too like I kind of am it's just like
it's so hard even I can't do it you know
what I'm saying yeah uh top comment says
having a public appearance on YouTube
and other social medias mean you are
going to be scrutinized they're going to
be hateful and hurtful comments from
Anonymous drones a lot of them are just
trolling or looking at a reaction Dan
Harmon talks about this on his podcast a
lot of celebrities like celebrities even
do this they so they avoid social media
for this very reason as it takes a toll
on your mental health it will only get
worse as you get more popular so you are
going to need to figure out a game plan
to save your mental health if you decide
to pursue this here are some suggestions
one avoid the comments yeah have Sarah
or someone else read through the
comments and give you the filtered
version two turn off comments where
possible three go into therapy and build
your tool set to be able to handle these
comments in a more productive manner
ultimately you cannot handle the crappy
comments then maybe it's if you if you
cannot then maybe it's time to evaluate
if it's worth it even Conan O'Brien says
how much he hates getting bad press and
reading bad press about himself
um he avoids it so much he said he has
his own staff pick the nicest articles
about him and only those are sent in his
way so even if like a celebrity like
you're not wrong for feeling this right
celebrities go through this too you know
and even they have to put Implement
things you know in their career to not
let this affect them as much so yeah but
also like having gone through it it's
almost like I may sound like completely
like not sympathetic at all but I think
it's just because there is nothing you
can do to change the outside world and
it's like it's cut and dry this is black
and white it's either you deal with it
or you need to get the [ __ ] out because
it is rough
so just be careful for those of you guys
out there who are like oh I want to be
YouTube and I want to do this and yeah
make sure you're ready for that people
always say it's about the journey not
the destination and you know what
they're right getting there effortlessly
is what Bays luggage and bags were made
for Bayes is right there for your
journey wherever your next destination
may be I got to say this is probably my
favorite sponsor that we have on the
show don't tell the other sponsors I
freaking love beige bags I swear they
are a game changer I forever was trying
to find the perfect bags that could hold
my laptop while being a carry-on while
not dropping my laptop while being easy
to take in and out of the bag to go
through security with and also hold all
my other stuff without cluttering the
bag and getting everything all jumbled
and oh my gosh everything about these is
designed to make my life easy I swear it
was like designed for me to make my life
easy and it's cute like so cute I got
the beige beige carry-on and Weekender
bag I do a little hack with my shoes
where I don't put my shoes in my roller
carry-on bag and I instead put them at
the bottom of the Weekender bag in the
zip up pouch and it saves so much room I
can pack so much more just with those
two bags alone and I love how there's a
little trolley on it so you can put it
on the handle of your rolling bag and
you don't have to carry it on your
shoulders I have scoliosis and it is a
problem carrying things on my shoulders
all the time but yeah I really think
bass is a thought of everything
everything you could ever want in one
piece of luggage 360 degree gliding
Wheels a cushioned handle built-in
weight indicator washable bags for your
dirty clothes and all the interior
Pockets you need to keep organized
whether you're packing for a quick trip
or looking to Breeze through the
security line phase has your personal
items covered and right now Bays is
offering our listeners 15 off your first
purchase by visiting basetravel.com big
mood that's
b-e-i-s-t-r-a-v-e-l.com slash big mood
go to basetravel.com big mood for 15 off
your first purchase that's b-e-i-s
travel.com slash big mood does your
probiotic contain clinically studied
strains we'll meet one that does rituals
symbiotic plus contains two of the
world's most studied strains with over
350 publications of human clinical
trials I really love ritual and I like
the symbiotic plus because I like that
it is a three in one clinically studied
Prebiotic probiotic and postbiotic to
support a balanced gut microbiome I like
that it is a single nested minty capsule
just one daily capsule to make it simple
get streamlined gut support I like that
the delayed release capsule is designed
to reach the colon not just the stomach
which is an ideal place for the
probiotics to survive and grow and also
I love that there is no Refrigeration
needed it's designed with moisture
controlled bottle technology to protect
the probiotic strains symbiotic plus and
ritual are here to celebrate not hide
your insides there's no more shame in
your gut game that's why ritual is
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
big mood to start ritual or add
symbiotic plus to your subscription
today that's ritual.com big mood to get
10 off for your first three months next
one
um he's 33 she's 27. he says my fiance
chose to save my deceased father stuff
over her deceased mother stuff in a fire
how can I ever repay her jeez wait wait
why is this a problem why is this a
problem it's like I don't know how to
repay her for her this is so sweet
that's just really cute but I don't know
she must have like been like uh my
relationship with my mom was whatever's
who I know you love your dad way more
than I love my mom what if they love
when she loved her mom so much too but
she's like
yeah wait fiance fiance okay two nights
ago my fiance accidentally set fire to
our kitchen and the fire extinguisher in
our apartment was defective the fire
spread quickly and burned through most
of the building before they were able to
contain it I wasn't home so I wasn't
there to help my girlfriend gather
anything if I was I would have forced
her outside and told her leave it all
it's just stuff she chose differently
first she took out the two dogs outside
and handed them off to a neighbor then
she went back in at this point the
kitchen was engulfed in flames and she
couldn't make it to the living room but
she could get into the bedroom she knew
she wouldn't be able to make two trips
so she had to act fast both of us lost
their appearance I lost my dad three
years ago he was a friend of her father
so she knew him though not very well but
he died before I actually met her I have
most of my dad's stuff in storage unit
but in our bedroom I have his ashes two
guns and a couple of other very personal
things from my time with him
she lost her mom as a teenager and
because her father is an [ __ ] she
only has a few small things of her in
her wedding dress
instead of choosing to save the few
things that she has of her mom she
gathered up my father's things wrapped
him in a sheet and ran out the room I
don't even know how to begin to say
thank you I'm so completely devastated
by her losing her mom's things like that
and I can't imagine what she was
thinking or how much she really must
love me to make that decision I don't
know how to repay her or where to begin
can anybody think of a nice gesture I
can make it up to her she must be
devastated I can't imagine losing the
last bit of my dad
I mean that's really sweet but what I
don't understand is why you feel like
you have to repay her in some way does
that make sense yeah I would feel or
like um not repair but I've a way to
make her there are some I appreciate
there are some things that you cannot
repay if that makes sense it's like you
can't
ever get back those things and what
could possibly
be in the place of your mother or her
possessions that you prized so there is
no what do you get what do you mean
repay her like there's there's no way to
do that I feel like there's definitely
nothing that can ever replace those you
know those those valuable things
but I think his way is just like what's
like he's not asking for what's enough
but more like what what are the best
things I can do like do I write a letter
say thank you do I get on my knees and
like you know hug her and cry and say
thank you I promise to eat your butthole
every night like what you know can even
get I know I wonder if nothing's close
like her mom's things were even like a
little bit like she's immediately she
like immediately thought to grab the
boyfriend's dad's things like I don't
know that is who knows that's either
weird like I mean the fact that she
still keeps it though means it means
something to her like she loves her mom
right and she doesn't have much yeah
yeah a wedding dress too like shoes and
then just fiance she's gonna get married
soon like
there's no I don't know to me it's weird
that he's like going on the internet and
asking how can I repay her like I get
that this is so sweet and he's so
appreciative but I'm like just be her
husband like be a good husband to her
and like but what I don't know I don't
know why this needs a Tit for Tat yeah
it's like
why does this why does he need to do
something now yeah you know what I mean
like I find that a weird reaction but
maybe I'm just weird I think it's sweet
like he and he's like I'm Gonna Make Her
brownies and that's gonna repay her like
what is the what do you think is what's
the answer to that there is nothing it's
like you got to just be her [ __ ] be
the best husband you can be yeah it's I
think it's you know obviously it's out
of being so sweet like
I understand the sentiment the truth of
the matter is there will be nothing that
can remember yeah but I like that he
even carries he's asking for ideas on
how to look at your name
so he wants ideas on how to like make
some Grand gesture because she feels
like yeah he feels like that she made a
grand gesture sometimes I feel that way
like when someone does something so
sweet for me I'm like oh my God like I
have to do something back and you feel
indebted but I don't know I just don't
think that that's how you go about
having a marriage is like being indebted
to each other because one person did
something Grand it's not indebted just
show appreciate some people are just not
good at showing appreciation yeah you
know so top comment says clearly in that
moment she chose to say what she loves
most of all your heart and your
happiness I think she thought to herself
to save what she had left which is you
she has all of her mom's memories
wrapped up inside her she didn't know
what losing your dad's stuff would do to
you so she decides to risk it and
protect you God damn that's powerful you
better marry that girl just spend the
rest of of your life treating her right
right yeah yeah so that's something but
obviously I'm sure he would so he just
wants to do something nice for her I
guess but it's weird to me that he has
to like ask other people what to do like
do it from your heart I think that's
what's bothering me is like why are you
asking strangers what you should do for
your wife whatever you think of the
things to do just aren't good at that
especially like there are some men who
just don't know how to show love very
well
um so yeah getting a little help doesn't
hurt I would definitely be writing to
the internet like help me figure
something out because I don't know like
yeah I find it strange I would I I think
it's sweet that he appreciates it but
just I feel like this whole situation is
weird yeah some people just aren't good
at it I don't know to me if I knew that
he like went to the internet and asked a
bunch of people what should I do I would
be like just [ __ ] it don't just don't I
don't need whatever you're gonna
contrived thing or you asked a stranger
to do for me like just be a really good
[ __ ] husband yeah you know like he
was asking like if there was any like
pieces of like burnt something yeah that
she that he can like try to gather and
be like yeah I know this isn't the same
thing but I made like this really
fireproof nice box for your mom's things
that are ashes now or like a shred of
the wedding dress and put it in like a
heart locket or something yeah oh this
one said the comment said my side note
um it would be nice to get something
engraved with her mother's name my best
friend's husband got her a ring with her
mom's name engraved on the inside and
their birthstone side by side in the
band so it's like even little things you
know like guys are sometimes real maybe
they're just so dumb that it's annoying
me that they're so bad at thinking of
things on their own maybe that's why I'm
annoyed yeah like if you want to do
something think of it yourself like I
don't know it's not that easy okay here
we go this is I don't blame him for
asking for help yeah I don't blame them
uh second comment says this is going to
sound corny but there may be no way to
repay her just be there for her and show
her your appreciation through actions
and behaviors in terms of those action
is there any way you can salvage any
carbon-based Burns no that's what you
said yeah so that's what so that speaks
out to me just be there for her and show
her your appreciation which for us seems
dull obviously yeah but for him it might
seem like but that's just not enough
like how do you show the appreciation
yeah or how like am I doing enough you
know because if this happened to me
obviously I would know there's no way I
can do enough but sometimes they just
need to hear the most simple answers
next one is I think okay I think what's
it's to going back to it because I'm
like why is this bothering me I think it
feels like it's it's bordering along the
lines of like conditional love like I
did this thing for you it's it's
teetering towards that to me like like I
need a Tit for Tat so that we're equal
or that we're even now or like like
little conditions like oh like if you do
something now I gotta do something and
then you do something I gotta do
something and then it just feels like
we're just like doing things just to do
things and it goes down this like long
list of like I don't know I don't know
it seems genuine anyone to me it's not
like oh she did this so I have to do it
right like she did this oh my God how
can I show her that thank you I love you
so much not like I have to do it back or
else it will be We're not gonna be yeah
yeah I don't know I'm gonna owe her yeah
like I owe her I'm indebted too you know
it just to me the it was so annoying and
I can't figure out why I don't know what
it is maybe I'll figure it out later but
I'm like this is so annoying the fact
that he's so I think I know maybe where
that's coming from okay for you what do
you think it is I think because in like
in your past and like especially in
relationships it really was like I did
this so now you owe me this and so like
it's just you felt indebted and you're
just like I don't want to be under
anyone's [ __ ] like what do you call
it I don't know it feels imprisoning
yeah like being like someone does a
gesture and now you have to [ __ ]
figure some [ __ ] out because maybe it's
a personal thing for not making why do
you gotta do something back like I just
love you you know yeah yeah that could
be it yeah yeah because if I was her I'm
not gonna lie like I saved your stuff
and if all you said was oh my God thank
you
I'd be like okay what I mean I wasn't
like it's not like I'm expecting like
you should do something for me well I
don't think that I I wouldn't do it as
like oh thanks he's like off-handed like
that yeah but it's just like once you
express emotion with your words and like
oh my God I can't believe you actually
saved my stuff over yours and like thank
you so much like but then it's just like
now you gotta go on the internet and
figure out this Grand [ __ ] gesture
that's gonna be good enough for maybe
for him it just doesn't seem like enough
like there's yeah he loves her so much
for himself yeah it was such a big thing
for him right you know so I think it was
it's probably just like triggering the
wrong part of me versus like I'm like
projecting on to him being annoyed by it
but yeah maybe you're used to like
things being so transactional that it's
hard for you to accept that people can
just do things out of kindness right
exactly which sucks yeah yeah
oh I hate people who [ __ ] make you do
things like make you feel like that yeah
okay
um my stepbrother 16 years old came to
my room I'm 16 also to level 16. step
brother yeah okay uh stepbrother and
she's a female 16 year old female my
stepbrother came to my room at night and
cut my hair with scissors oh my God at
16. that's like five years old [ __ ] yeah
I moved out my parents still want me
back or my parents want me back with him
still there what wait where she moved to
who the [ __ ] would cut why yeah that's
really weird what the [ __ ] was I'm
wondering if he was justified anyway
because she probably [ __ ] up or he's
just [ __ ] insane okay my stepbrother
of six months my Mom married his dad
so a few weeks ago in the morning I
noticed my stuff in my room had been
moved I told my brother my actual
biological full blood brother who's 23
years old and he didn't take me
seriously but taught me how to record my
room at nights with my phone I've been
recording myself every night nothing
happened so I was ready to believe that
nothing had happened that night how did
she do this I want to know how to do
this all right this week however my
stepbrother came into my room at around
3 15 a.m he came to me with scissors cut
a small piece of my hair and left my
room oh [ __ ] so it wasn't like a big
chunk it was like like a little
witchcraft chunk yeah is it like what
I'm thinking angry big chunk or creepy
small trunk he's gonna eat it
um that's [ __ ] weird it was so weird
and shocking it was a very small amount
nothing like I wouldn't have or nothing
that I would have noticed I sent the
video to my siblings I have a biological
brother and also a biological sister
who's 19. they told me to pack a bag
immediately and pick me up and took me
with them they sent the video so that's
where she went
parents questioned The Stepbrother he
says he doesn't remember doing it at all
he said he was likely sleepwalking as to
see a doctor that's some [ __ ] oh my
God for sure I don't believe him and
neither do my siblings parents want to
solve this problem by taking both of us
to family therapy they want me to come
home and discuss this all of us
um they say I'm not in any real danger
as he didn't hurt me or do anything
inappropriate or sexual inappropriate
yeah and we don't even know yet if it's
sexual or not exactly my siblings
strongly disagree and say that what he
did was very inappropriate and they're
not going to let me go back there as
long as my stepbrother still lives there
yep parents say they will install a lock
on my door so that I can lock myself in
at night stepfather is upset at my
siblings and claims they've turned this
into a much larger issue than it is oh
my god [ __ ] your kid is [ __ ] psycho
go handle your son but he says that they
could have just parented the problem
away by punishing it's not a big deal
honestly I keep hearing everyone's
strong opinions about this and I don't
know who's right or wrong what should I
do do I go back do I just never go back
my breast my best friend says I should
go to the police and press charges
against step brother I don't think
that's something that's a little bit
yeah what the [ __ ] I can't think of any
situation where it's okay to cut
someone's hair while they're sleeping
and just taking it weird also what was
the stuff that was moved around like
what did like did he take something like
does she notice if
behavior that could devolve into
something much worse so like what's
happened so far is not really that bad
yet right obviously it's like okay the
end result is a piece of her hair is
missing yeah but it's like it's like
what is to come is what's scary like
what is this leading to why is he doing
this and where is it gonna go also why
does she need to live there
she's 16. yeah but like but but she's
being taken care of by her siblings too
I don't know maybe it's just like a
harder situation like maybe it's just
easier back at the other house but I
know yeah I don't know that's God first
of all a lock on the door for sure yeah
I feel like I've always had locks on my
door too so I'm surprised that they
don't have locks already but I didn't I
guess some houses don't have them
especially when there's boys like
teenage boys teenage girls not even
blood related like we need some privacy
we need some locks on the doors yeah so
she says um I guess somebody asked her
were there any other problems she's like
no problems that I know of he certainly
is a strange person but I wouldn't have
said he was creepy until this happened I
never felt I was in danger around him
someone else says Hey listen considering
how your stepdad is trying to brush us
aside I'm 100 sure that there has been
other behaviors he's exhibited that has
been ignored by his dad he needs help
yeah you don't need to be put in danger
in the meantime stay with your siblings
yeah uh top comments are saying listen
to your siblings your mom wants you to
just grin and bear it so she can have a
happy little home with her new husband
both of them are in denial over how
serious the situation is your
stepbrother for sure needs therapy but
you do not need to be in the house nope
when that happens yeah stay away oh God
I'm so good yeah everyone's creeped out
by this guy yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] weird
yeah like what else has his Dad brushed
is there any updates on this one because
I don't know what that's just so weird
to me that I don't even know I can't
even guess what's right going on with
this kid there is no update and what
what the [ __ ] is up with the mom she's
gonna pick me there's so many moms like
that it's like just yeah yeah
selfish nothing was missing from any
time before he was in the room this is
the salt your stepbrother is a creep you
are not safe in your own home stay with
your siblings he will most likely
escalate his behavior and do other
things to your body while you're asleep
that wouldn't make me feel weird I feel
gross it's also it's triggering me from
my past experiences
I used to have I used to um
because my door didn't have a lock when
I was a kid and I would lay out towels
and blankets in front of my closed door
because my door would open in right so
I'd lay out towels and blankets on under
my door just to make sure no one would
walk in well they could still walk in
right no no yeah but it to know if they
came in or not so then what would you
what did anyone ever walk in and you saw
that the towels removed yeah and then
what I knew yeah there was nothing else
I could do yeah and you're just like I
at least it was like evidence crazy yeah
you were like proving to yourself that
you weren't crazy yeah exactly my dad
used to like forbid us from going into
his room because like we would always
mess up [ __ ] and jump in the bed and
[ __ ] yeah
um so he so while he was off at work or
before he left to work his trick was he
laid a single hair
on a table and if it's gone that means
we were in his room a single hair like
the AC could kick off
okay greasy or anything so like if
someone came in he would know or he took
my brother once because my brother used
to um like in the middle of the night
sneak into the living room play video
games he put
giant Globs of Vaseline on the hand like
game controller so he would like if my
brother grabbed it he's he'll see like
indentations and stuff in the Vaseline
stuff
yeah that was really creepy I would not
want to stay in the same house [ __ ] no
and I'm so [ __ ] curious to know what
the [ __ ] he's doing with his hair yes
and I'm also so glad she has siblings to
stay with she's not stuck in that house
by herself all right so in my household
I have two trash cans one of them it's a
bigger one for all the non-food like not
wet stuff that won't stick up the trash
the second bin is for all the food waste
and that little Trash Can I cannot tell
you how many times even per day do we
have to throw out that it's smaller
trash because it smells it fills up so
quickly not a big fan I hate it it's
just been so gross so luckily about a
month ago I received a loamy and loamy's
is really cool countertop electric
composter that turns scraps to dirt in
under four hours and there is absolutely
no smell when it runs and it's super
quiet I love the fact that loamy allows
me to turn my food scraps into dirt with
a push of a button thanks to lomia have
way less garbage each week we used to
throw away about like two to three bags
per day of food scraps away but now I
end up just having the low me on my
countertop and we fill that sucker up
and about once every two days I would
say is when we run it and I'm telling
you it does not smell at all and I love
the fact that now we don't have to throw
out a stinky bag of garbage in the trash
now it's just this beautiful soil that I
can use for my potted plants and
whenever I don't need soil for my plants
I end up just throwing it in the green
garbage bin for landscape waste I don't
know just made our life at home so much
easier especially my son loves it
because he's in charge of throwing out
the trash and he just loves only having
to deal with non-stinky dirt now our
family really loves it and I honestly
think it's a great gift idea you know
with the holidays coming up I would gift
this to the go conscious person in your
life or someone who you know ends up
having lost lots of food waste totally
worth it especially for us in particular
you know we just had Thanksgiving and oh
my goodness normally getting rid of all
that food waste would have been like
bags and bags of trash but no we just
threw it all in the loamy and within
four hours we had dirt it was amazing I
love it so if you want to start making a
positive environmental impact or just
make cleanup after dinner that much
easier Lomi is perfect for you head to
loamy.com Big mood and use promo code
big mood to get 50 off your loamy that's
fifty dollars off when you head to
l-o-m-i.com slash big mood and use code
big mood at checkout food waste is gross
loamy is your solution with the holidays
just around the corner Lomi will make
the perfect gift for someone on your
shopping list next one I 29 year old
male just spent another awkward holiday
with my girlfriend's Rich family she's
28 year old email my girlfriend I have
been together for almost three years 99
of the time were great she's funny smart
we have a lot of shared interests but
every time we visit her we we visit her
family I start doubting everything they
are very wealthy which by itself is not
a bad thing but they're also very
fixated on being rich and have a habit
of placing the monetary value on things
or other things and people over
everything else I come from a very
middle class background I have a good
education and a decent career that I
really enjoy but I'm definitely not rich
because of this they view me as a loser
for example yesterday we made the
two-hour drive to our parents in my
newish Honda when we got there my mom
immediately ordered me to park the car
behind the house so the neighbors
wouldn't see it her mom her mom yeah
yeah
there's a lot of rich people that drive
[ __ ] regular yeah like these are like
weird these are insecure these are
insecure rich people because there's a
ton of very wealthy people there's
probably new money yeah there's new
money well I don't know something
something's triggering me on that I'm
like there's I know so many people I
grew up around rich people and a lot of
them would have very base or at least
have like multiples of everything and
then like they would all often in times
go into public with the cheaper thing to
kind of fit in or whatever you know I've
never known anyone very wealthy I grew
up on an island so it was either poor
people who were the service workers or
the rich [ __ ] people who had the
Mansions yeah I know Myspace Tom
do you do yes he used to date my
girlfriend his daily is a [ __ ] Prius
right so these people are [ __ ]
they're just weirdos they're so stupid
um and plus if you go around La and you
go into like the really rich areas
there's so many Giants yeah which is
what their cars in the front yeah insane
um she was Furious we didn't uh the mom
was Furious we didn't bring the
girlfriend's Land Rover which they
bought for his birthday gift this year
my girlfriend doesn't like to drive long
trips and I'm not allowed to drive the
Land Rover for her parents what so we
brought my Honda they actually [ __ ]
follow that rule wow how do you actually
follow that rule like
girlfriend's dad has never spoken me
directly oh my God even when she
introduced me the first time he turned
to her and said what does he do oh geez
so yeah they're insecure yeah yeah for
sure so we went in the house and I gave
her dad the usual hi Merry Christmas and
he gave me the usual disinterested
glance one more example last year I made
the mistake of bringing a bottle of wine
it was a 25 bottle which was pricey for
me and I even had the wine store lady
help me pick it out oh girlfriend's mom
told me to put it in the kitchen they
didn't open it while we were there and
she later admitted to the girlfriend
they'd re-gifted it to the housekeeper
because it was quote gas station Hooch
wow why would this girlfriend repeat
this to her boyfriend yeah I don't know
why she's letting him know how shitty
her parents are reacting to him maybe
she was brace rich and she doesn't have
those socials like she doesn't know like
yeah to not tell him that they gave the
wine to the housekeeper but to add the
[ __ ] gas station Hooch that's just
like why maybe she was also I mean do
you think she's a little self-aware like
that her parents are [ __ ] and she
was like commiserating like oh my mom's
such a [ __ ] she like gave the gift away
possibly maybe we managed because he
likes her he likes her
we managed to get through the day
yesterday without much drama except the
car thing which I'd normally consider a
win but today I keep thinking about the
whole situation with their family and
wondering if I'm really willing to deal
with these people for the rest of my
life girlfriend and I have tossed around
the possibility of getting married more
than once but I know they'll never
accept me if we get married I'll have to
see them a lot more than once a year
girlfriend has given up on trying to
defend me to her parents and just
ignores her [ __ ] most of the time
but I can tell it bothers her too
they bankroll a big chunk of her
lifestyle and I think she's worried
they'll cut her off if she pushes yeah
Marcus I don't know if this is gonna
work so not to sound like an [ __ ] but
am I wasting my time is this
relationship doomed I think yes
girlfriend always tells me she doesn't
care what her family thinks but um
it's gonna escalate I like the top
comment the problem isn't that they're
rich it's that they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah I well that's like a
caricature of rich people I don't care
the last person I dated was a lawyer and
he came from a very rich Taiwanese
family and sometimes I thought about
that too because my dad and my like my
family were not that at all you know
like
um his parents were the type that's like
when he went off to college in another
state they came and they would apartment
shop with him and be like no the cars
aren't nice enough here this is ghetto
or like they're also like so [ __ ]
they were shitty like yeah a black
person walks by the car they lock their
doors immediately kind of people yeah
and the thought did cross my mind like I
wonder if this will ever work out in the
long run because of our families and
that it really reached the point where
well he always sure like no no it
wouldn't matter at all I don't care what
my parents think blah blah but one time
we had an argument about like what we
were taught when we were kids and he
said well I think I trust my parents
with their higher education that I would
trust yours oh gee it's definitely
ingrained yeah and I said where you came
from is ingrained in you yeah good or
bad and I said okay I don't care because
my dad can probably [ __ ] up both your
appearance
but yeah when it comes to like
differences like this
it's kind of hard to [ __ ] yeah I
don't they suck I mean honestly like I
get that
there's a class issue sometimes like
maybe but it but like most wealthy
people that I know that aren't insecure
like they understand that like oh well
if we have to if we're so wealthy that
we're going to events and you're like
uncultured whatever like we'll just put
you in classes like we'll get you
[ __ ] etiquette classes like we'll
just fix you you know what I mean like
just they kind of know that it's
[ __ ] too yeah but they're like
they're just a part of that Society so
but they wouldn't be like oh you just
have no worth as a person yeah get your
Honda out of here nothing like looking
at him no that's ridiculous that not
every rich person is like that that's
ridiculous deeply deep ingrained
insecurity yeah it's not gonna get fixed
I feel like they're miserable miserable
themselves because
they're constantly doing the whole like
keeping up with the Joneses kind of
thing and they're just too far that's
too far yeah they're like what would the
neighbors think like holy [ __ ] I don't
know you might think your [ __ ] Maids
are here cleaning your house who cares
yeah like who cares you go down Beverly
Hills Dry it's just like shitty old cars
all the way I'm like these look like the
mates cars you know it's Maids gardeners
whatever the [ __ ] it is like who [ __ ]
cares that there's a Honda in front of
your house yeah like no one cares but to
the point where like oh this wine is
cheap I wouldn't even put it inside me
like dude shut the [ __ ] up ridiculous
nobody likes you people just tolerate
you that's all I feel like that he's
just he should just walk away
because I mean clearly the the
girlfriend does care what her parents
are saying if she's not even allowing
him to drive like he doesn't actually
get to drive the [ __ ] car get out of
here yeah she's not she's not adorning
him with what she has she's still
allowing him to be the other you know
what I mean like if I had all this [ __ ]
and I didn't give a [ __ ] I'd be like
just grab my [ __ ] Carnival like we'll
switch at the gas station before we get
to my parents house just so they shut up
but like my shoes I don't care like my
shit's your [ __ ] it doesn't matter
they're they're stupid but I don't
believe that like if she was supporting
him or adorning him more with like what
she has and not making a big deal I
don't think he would feel so other
either because he's just like whoa what
is what's going on here so there is an
update he said um okay so this post blew
up and my girlfriend actually saw it
yeah and then he got a text from her
saying in all caps we need to talk
obviously you do she said she was
feeling hurt and angry when she sent
that text but she said she had time to
read through the comments and think
about things and she wasn't upset when
she came to my apartment later she still
said that or she said that still I had
no right to tell the whole internet
internet about our relationship problems
the parents are like oh my God what is
the internet gonna think of us who they
don't even know yeah exactly
yeah
her
parents
um we talked for a long time Thursday
she said she knows her parents treat
people like [ __ ] and that they control
her and her siblings with money it's
partially a cultural thing according to
her girlfriend was born and raised in
the US and her parents grew up in a rich
in a different country and moved here a
long time ago she said they had a hard
time assimilating with upper-class
Americans and Flawless
insecure there it is girlfriend also
implied that kind of behavior was a lot
more acceptable in their home country in
the 1980s and they never really [ __ ] is
this Home Country
um Mexico oh so to her
um in Mexico there he is it's judgmental
yeah super about yeah who's got money
who doesn't like we're up here you're
down there there's no product of that
environment though being like dog eat
dog yeah it's unstable on top of that
girlfriend's mom was Slash is
emotionally and physically abusive she
said her mom used to slap her for
talking back and once cut up all the
girlfriend's clothes and bedding after
an argument after going out with some
high school friends girlfriend says
she's still afraid of her mom and has a
hard time standing up to her she also
has very little affection from her
parents growing up there's also cycle
that's a cycle of abuse yeah yeah so her
being cut off from her family
financially is the same as being cut off
emotionally all that being said
she's like I don't want to let go this
money I don't get so I don't get
anything else don't let me don't make me
get rid of this money
um all that being said we've been um
she said that she was very apologetic
and she doesn't expect me to visit her
parents again she was really hurt that I
said I thought I was wasting my time in
the earlier post and I said I was sorry
okay cool cool
um we've been talking about moving in
together for a while now she actually
suggested she move out of her townhouse
that her family pays for and into an
apartment I'm totally fine with this
we're not combining our finances or
putting her name on the lease the plan
for now is to split the cost of rent
blah blah blah they're gonna move in
together girlfriend has a job in her own
income she is the co-owner for business
makes a decent living
um yeah I feel like unless she's like
basically is able to reach a common
ground with their parents like look I
get you don't like him and like you're
concerned that he's poor or whatever but
I would like to have you in my life
um I'm gonna stay with him like you know
what I mean like she's gotta she's gotta
say something to kind of stop the
bleeding or get cut off or let go of him
because this is not gonna go away yeah
she's not you can't she can't
compartmentalize her life like this yeah
right like this is they're they're
freaking out because they realize that
it's not gonna work out so they're
trying to like scramble to make this
work but I just don't see it working
yeah well it seems like here things are
moving for the better because she is
seriously contemplating like I have my
own life being cut off being cut off
okay yeah well for how long we'll see
she's gonna start resenting him because
she got cut off for him every time they
get into a fight she's like I left the
[ __ ] money for you that's right oh
you better not move it over his head oh
[ __ ] top comment says honestly her
seeing the posts and comments and
realizing it was about her was probably
the best thing that can happen to your
relationship sounds like it's been a
real eye-opener and like she's serious
about making the change it's always
going to be a battle with those parents
but should also make your relationship
stronger good luck I hope so yeah I mean
odds are not in your favor no but I she
I will give her the benefit of the doubt
but I don't know man
as soon as some [ __ ] gets rough
oh boy yeah that that's rough that's
yikes I don't know man
well I mean it's it's a good thing she
like self-reflected though yeah there's
some growth there she knows she knows
all right next one says I am a 26 male
um and I upset a woman and my friends
are acting like I'm in the wrong okay so
your friends already don't aren't on
your side is not a good sign
he's 26 this woman that he upset is in
her 20s
I went out clubbing last night with my
friends there were seven of us three
guys including me and four girls my
girlfriend Hannah was meant to come too
but she was feeling ill I offered to
stay I want to assume that this [ __ ]
tried to hit on him or something I don't
know I offered to stay in with her when
she insisted I go out and have a good
time at the club my friends got to
talking to a group of women who
apparently work in finance they were
here for some sort of conference and
were checking out the local places in
their spare time one of them Lauren
started trying to chat to me and asked
for my number she was pretty but see
she was pretty but I was not interested
as I have a girlfriend I told her this
but then she started asking for pictures
of my girlfriend Hannah weird I showed
her and she said that I quote could do
better than that why are you even
interacting with in this [ __ ]
conversation Lauren are you not
embarrassed that is why is he why is he
entertaining this [ __ ] also there is
a possibility that he might be like
exaggerating to make himself sound
better maybe maybe just maybe I was
annoyed and told her to leave me alone
later me and my friends were dancing and
Lauren and her group came up to us and
she started trying to dance with me I
gave her the brush off once again and I
moved away from her and she gave me a
dirty look a while later she came back
how dare you not want me right yeah this
girl definitely exists I believe it oh
yeah yeah
yes I'm not saying she doesn't yeah a
while later she came back and by that
point she was really drunk she smirked
at me and threw her drink in my face oh
damn I was absolutely fuming and in
response I poured my beer on her head
she started crying and ran through the
bouncer who got us all kicked out
everyone then proceeded to have a go at
me I understand they were annoyed that
we were kicked out but everyone was
acting like I was wrong to pour my drink
on her they all saw her Splash her drink
in my face but everyone was saying it
was nasty to do that to a girl the
ladies in our group were talking about
how upset they'd become if someone
ruined their dress hair and makeup by
doing that but she literally she started
it yeah she did that to him but when I
pointed out that she did the same thing
to me everyone said that it wasn't the
same nobody said good goodbye to me last
night and I made my own way home I told
Hannah what happened and she agrees I
didn't do anything wrong I tried
explaining myself over the group chat
but everyone ignored me how do I sort
this out yeah I don't know [ __ ] your
face yeah
I started on your friend's side but I'm
like what if she literally doused you in
a drink yeah and then you did the exact
same thing yeah unless he did it in like
a meaner way and he's not including it
like if he like kind of hit her yeah or
like you know kind of like was more
disgusting with it I can see like him
like taking it up a notch and being like
more disgusting and abusive in the way
he would retaliate but if it was just
like a splash and a splash it's like
well [ __ ] don't don't start no [ __ ]
there won't be no [ __ ] yeah you know
like why was she obsessed with him all
night and like not leaving him alone
take no for an answer Jesus Christ that
is yeah that's weird weird don't expect
to hit someone and not get hit back I
wonder if his friends noticed that she
was just like on him and that he was
rejecting creepy because
if they didn't notice that either then
it might just look like a blow up yeah
exactly like what the [ __ ] happened here
well even though even if they didn't
notice like the all her like hitting on
him the whole night they he said that
they did see that she threw a drink in
his face right so so because at that
point it could still be deserved from
him oh she's exactly and he retaliated
yeah exactly I guess so I mean but he
you know I think he's trying to explain
us and all the girls and everyone's all
mad at him yeah I must I feel like he
must have retaliated like you know like
if someone does this and then you
[ __ ] go wham yeah like it's like whoa
dude your retaliation especially to a
chick was a lot right but if it was Tit
for Tat evenly small I don't get it why
are his friends being weird yeah like I
would be like bro maybe don't try to
retaliate on a girl but I get it like
she did hit you with the drinks yeah
top comment is get new friends
your friends are stupid they were only
saying that's Justified their anger
towards you since you were quote the
reason their Knight of fun ended if you
want to handle this maturely show them
this Reddit post so you can so they can
see what the situation looks like from a
third person's perspective then maybe if
they're not complete idiots they'll
change their stance also invite them
over for a barbecue and have a bunch of
beers lined up to pour on them
no yeah that's a good point that they
bring up though because they did end up
getting kicked out because of him
because a girl snitched so I could see
and then they're all they've all been
drinking yeah so they're just not
thinking very rationally oh God hearing
about desperate people like that can't
say I can't say no makes me like oh it's
weird too like if she was pretty because
you said she was pretty so she's already
like pretty that's why I could probably
get in yeah she's probably like what
I've never been rejected before now how
do I act you know like like a psycho let
me want you more creepy next one I don't
want to take part in my girlfriend's sex
ritual on our wedding night sex ritual
wait girlfriend yeah not fiance well but
I still want to marry her I don't know
okay same thing yeah um weird so I'm 23
getting married to my girlfriend who's
also 23. yeah so yeah yeah we're getting
married early next year if all goes to
plan I don't have a lot of family
um she however has a huge extended
family for the most part we get on great
for the most part
with her extended family I don't know
they oh yeah yeah with the family they
tend to be very loud and have huge
personalities which is sometimes hard
for me to deal with since I've always
been like on the quiet side but overall
very warm and caring people something
weird I've noticed since we got engaged
is that my girlfriend's cousins
sometimes makes jokes about our wedding
night it's weird for them to joke about
it since I'm pretty sure our family is
aware we've slept together before since
we shared a bed at holiday Gatherings
and vacations a few nights ago we were
discussing wedding plans and thinking
about places to go on our honeymoon my
girlfriend and I were brainstorming
ideas when she tells me that we won't
need a bridal Suite get a bridal Suite
right away obviously I asked why we're
getting married at a pretty nice hotel
and she says that she'd like for us to
stay at her parents house I don't really
mind this we're trying to save money for
a house deposit anyways but girlfriend
seems like she has more to say so I push
on why she wants to stay at her parents
house she tells me there's a really old
tradition in her family on a wedding
night on the wedding night the tradition
is the husband and the wife go into the
master bedroom together and they are
supposed to consummate the marriage in
the family home the rest of the family
are waiting outside the door so they're
gonna plot them good guys no and then
some old school [ __ ] and then cheer when
they come out okay what religion is this
this is some old school [ __ ] yeah I've
seen or heard something like this
somehow yeah there's like in a movie or
something this is like some really old
world stuff
then a piece of the bed sheet is cut off
and sewn into a big tapestry my
girlfriend's mother owns yeah that is
[ __ ] creepy my girlfriend saw that I
wasn't happy because she quickly told me
that we wouldn't have to actually
consummate the marriage if I felt
uncomfortable and we can just pretend I
don't want anything to do with this I
absolutely freaked out and told her
under no circumstances while I'd be
doing that kind of thing in front of her
whole family does he not know what
religion they are or like he doesn't
know anything about her culture and
they're getting married yeah it looks
like she kept this from him because she
was hesitant to tell him that's okay
that's weird that's weird bring that in
at the last minute right like all the
tapestry also it's weird that he's not
down to just pretend like okay chill
yeah pretend that yeah when I came back
from talk taking a walk to clear my head
she was now noticeably acting down and
still is I think she's still she's been
texting her family about this because I
received a text from her mother telling
me that I quote don't understand the
importance of family and tradition yet
and this kind of tradition has been
around longer than I've been alive I
don't know how minutes go on from here I
really love my girlfriend but I I I'm
freaked out of course but she's my whole
world I don't know how to handle this
and navigate this tradition he's
probably just wondering like what else
don't I know about her culture and what
else what else is going to happen later
like once we're actually married which
is even harder to get out of it's like
do I need to impregnate you in front of
everyone too to see the blood on the
[ __ ] so make sure you're a virgin
yeah what he needs to do first is get
acquainted with her culture and learn
everything that he's signing up for yeah
don't get married yet because if you
don't understand the religion and you're
not down for it then this is a recipe
for terrible disaster and she's just
gonna feel like rejected left and right
from him because he's like what is this
weird [ __ ] you know what I mean also
it's her fault why the [ __ ] is she not
being open about yeah she's not telling
him what her her religion or her culture
is and so he's like getting blindsided I
can like so they have a tapestry can you
imagine having a tapestry of like all
the pieces of bed sheets that everyone
in your family has banged on on their
wedding nights yeah I don't understand
it but there's a lot of weird things and
a lot of weird religions how do you even
introduce like oh yeah this is worried
me and your mom boned and one day you're
gonna be up here too that's [ __ ] way
hi Papa one day sweetheart you know I
find most surgeons to be weird I mean
that's why I'm kind of agnostic because
I'm like I don't understand it but it's
people can have their [ __ ] but also when
you marry into it you need to do your
due diligence and like she needs to be
totally helpful and explaining and
transparent of like what their culture
and their Traditions are like do you
want to sign up for this or not yeah
what would you guys see what you guys
think they're too young they're just too
young personally yeah they're super
young I wouldn't pretend no I would do
my due diligence and figure out what is
this what's going on what am I signing
up for what's next what's going to be
coming after that no for sure do that
but personally for me I wouldn't mind
just going along with it if I was him or
I'm like this isn't a big deal sure like
this is weird creepy I want to know what
the [ __ ] is next but sure I'll pretend
I'm [ __ ] you in your parents bedroom
uh someone says maybe you need to ask if
there's any more traditional rituals
that you had to do before agreeing to
marry her do they have a religion he
hasn't responded he has
[ __ ] that's so weird just
imagine he's like accidentally falling
into some like mid-summer right like
it's some crazy culty thing I I don't
know what religion that is I feel like
I've heard of that before I have he
could just be trolling I don't know is
this a real post that just seems so old
world to me that I'm like who's
practicing that still you know what I
mean like I don't I don't know but maybe
there's some
uh top comment says tell them you'll do
it in return for a dowry of a hundred
head of cattle a white stallion and a
track of arable land terrible
[Applause]
or it's suitable for growing crops okay
come on yeah
I think I can never even I feel like
though I mean they're kids first of all
second like I mean as an adult now like
if I dated someone and they're like oh
I'm such and such religion I would be
like okay cool how deep are you into it
how much do you follow that tradition
are you okay with the fact that I'm
agnostic and I'm probably not going to
do the things you're doing but I'm
supportive of you doing them but like
don't expect me to do them is this okay
yeah if it's not okay then that's why a
lot of people stay in their culture or
stay in their religion because some of
those things are so important that not
what do they call it being yoked the
same or whatever like if you're not on
the same page like that that is a recipe
for a divorce yeah yeah I wouldn't be
able to I can't even have sex when I
know my friends are in the Next Room yes
I have roommates home sometimes like I
have to say so unlike some of our
friends yeah
tear the house down even though we're
like one wall away I don't even know how
guys can like if I was a guy I would
ever even perform knowing her whole
family is outside the door and it's like
creepy like your dad and your mom's like
pushing their ear against the door like
why weird why why everyone has their
weird religion like honestly even some
Christian things now still I find to be
weird like drinking the blood of Christ
or whatever I'm just like what like
we've been conditioned into the things
that we're familiar with with like the
Christian stuff and like the stuff that
we're like there's probably countless
traditions and where I'm like all of
this shit's weird yeah like why are we
doing any of it I don't know
cannibalistic yeah yeah oh this is a
weird one but so yeah but it's like if
you like that that's fine do you
but you need to figure out if you can be
in that marriage all right that's the
end of our episode thanks for watching
uh leave your opinions Below on this
[ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ] we've been
talking about oh God people's drama is
so good other people's drama delicious
um but thanks for watching check out our
sponsors in the description box and uh
like us subscribe to us and we'll see
you guys next week we love you bye thank
you bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]